so people walking in right now my name
is Alan Underwood again I do I'm coming
through the speakers it sounds like
right yeah everything's good all right
cool so I do a podcast called coding
blocks been doing it for about six years
with two other guys it's it's just the
three of us we don't do interviews we
basically just talk about all the stuff
that you guys probably talk about when
you're at work right like man there's
this problem how do we solve it what do
we do right and it's three different
perspectives on that and so that's what
we do right we've got a decent following
and this is my first time actually
coming out internationally and speaking
so this is kind of fun I'm a Microsoft
MVP I feel kind of bad because I saw
people put that up on their screens I
didn't have the logo so um I'm an MVP
and uh I've recently I said recently
within the past year gotten into
streaming stuff so and we'll talk about
why here in a second so again everybody
that came in if you want a chance to win
the air pods tweet put a photo do
something funny whatever just make it
fun and put in DC London on there and
you have a chance to win the air pods
after this talk that's a fail really see
this is what happens when you buy nice
technology to come to a talk no no I did
when I was staying up till two o'clock
in the morning every night you know I
was sitting there with the clicker doing
it all no no that you could apparently
like plug this thing in for like two
minutes and it'll do its thing you have
to be freaking kidding me
that's so frustrating
$90 paperweight and if this doesn't work
I'll be fine because I'll just come over
here and click the keyboard you know
what it is
I'm not on the PowerPoint no there's got
to be whatever I'll walk back and forth
okay so the first slide the reason
you're wondering why am I talking about
Donuts right so is anybody ever made
donuts at home before anybody not many
right it's actually a chore right like
it's it's a it's a fairly intense
process and I've got kids so this is
what everything looks like in my house
any given time right and when you do
donuts there's a lot of flour there's a
lot of things so this is what it turns
out being but that's not the important
part what I want to get out here is it's
very much a bachelor init process you do
something you finish that then you move
on to the next step so after you get the
dough all set up made out then you got
to roll it out you got to cut it you get
all these things cut out you roll the
doles the dough to some more and you
keep doing this right after that you
take it you drop it into the fryer which
is only like a minute per side that was
kind of shocking too when I first did
this for whatever reason I thought it
was a longer process and then the
glorious part right you put the stuff on
there that people actually want to eat
after that you put it in the oven you
bake them right that's the way that you
do things like even if you're doing
cookies or anything like that it's very
much a step-by-step process and you
can't do the next thing until the
previous ones done right and that's very
much how batch type things are well I
think when I first started getting into
Kafka and streams I had gone into a
Krispy kream because my kids saw one
they're like that we need donuts oh of
course you do
so we went in here and I'm watching this
thing it was fascinating so I've got a
little video here you go that's
unbelievable
everything goes wrong during the demos
right
well bear with me it's like a one-minute
video but it will absolutely without it
it's not going to be all that
interesting man it won't play it doesn't
even give me the button to click it
there we go
all right so checked it but it's not
showing it's not showing up there
chilling here
see that's that's mine that's not what's
up on the screen just that one yeah just
so can I go out of presenter mode okay
check it out I'm gonna play this thing
here maybe that'll work and then you
should be able to see it so let's talk
to you this so the way things work at
Krispy Kreme is the way the dough's made
is it's actually squirted out of these
nozzles right so this stuffs all
happening at the same time and if you've
ever gone to a Krispy Kreme that has
this it's really cool and then instead
of you actually doing things as these
things come down the conveyor they get
thrown into these things where they let
this stuff rise right so this is all
happening concurrently now when it's
going through the fryer it actually
swims down through a pool of this stuff
and so you have things happening in
parallel the whole time you're no longer
there's not somebody back there rolling
dough and all that kind of stuff this is
all continuously going right so as
dough's being made right now this
stuff's also going down the stream and
it goes through this wall of amazingness
I mean that's that's pretty awesome so
as you can see this is like what I was
looking at this I was like oh this is
amazing they took they took this problem
where people actually had to go through
stuff and they turn it into this
parallelization right like this thing
where they have multiple streams of this
working and the only thing that's
stopping them from doing more is the
amount of space that they have for
having these things set up right so
let's get back in here I know that we've
got the the one thing out of the way
they could potentially go wrong with
this all right so now let's talk about
what probably most people are familiar
with which is I mean I've been a
developer for probably about 20 years
and this is kind of the way the world's
worked for a long time is you have your
database right like everybody's familiar
with this all your data is going in
there and all of a sudden you need to
start getting data and you start these
processes at midnight right because
that's when everybody's asleep nobody's
on the system so you start pulling data
in so you grab some stuff from the data
warehouse because you need to enrich
your customer information right then
let's say that you want to go get some
social data Facebook has all your
information all right so
you grab stuff from Facebook because you
want to enrich your data even more maybe
you want to find out buying patterns the
stuff that people are looking at so that
happened two hours later because you
needed to wait for your load from the
data warehouse to finish right and then
at 3:00 a.m. because Facebook has all
your data you're gonna go get some more
right and again you're waiting until the
previous one's done before you go on to
the next one then after you get all the
data and you're going to start
transforming that you're gonna put that
data together you're gonna try and make
sense of it and you're gonna use it at
some point and then maybe you're gonna
start generating reports after you put
all that data together so that the next
morning when people come in they can
start working on their day job right on
the previous day's data this is
something that I would venture to say
most of you are familiar with I mean
this is this is kind of how business has
gone for a long time and then you pray
that by the time everybody gets in
everything's gone right and not one of
these data loads failed because I didn't
evitable ii happens right all the data
warehouse was down Oh Facebook their API
wasn't working whatever right this is
basically what happens and if something
did go wrong sorry
hopefully we'll have it up this
afternoon maybe maybe it'll be the next
day right so this is this is kind of the
standard way that everybody's lived for
years this is really squeaky um anybody
that's ever worked with sequel server
and done any data transformations ETL
this is a small you know little view of
what that can look like and and it's
very much a linear thing right like that
thing at the top has to finish before
these next ones kick off and then this
next one has to happen for those go
right and you can see the things
starting green some of them yellow while
they're working whatever and this is
this is standard and this is the way
that we've worked for years and years so
what's wrong with it
maybe nothing right if that works for
you you don't have data that's killing
your systems there's not too much coming
in whatever maybe that's fine right and
maybe if you only care about getting
that data a couple of times a day maybe
that's fine too right like you don't
care about data coming in all the time
but what if it's taking too long right
maybe this is your primary database and
everybody's using it right
how many of you use a database server
and have abused it beyond what it's
supposed to be right like it's a
transactional database but now it's your
reporting server at your warehouse at
your web front-end it's all that like
that's what most people do because what
what I like to say is when you have a
hammer everything looks like a nail
right and that's that's basically what
people treat their databases like and it
starts slowing down right you might have
i/o constraints the disks aren't fast
enough or you have too many things
coming in or you have transactions that
are blocking other things right um so
the locking contention um let's say that
that thing with the data where the data
warehouse happened
you didn't get it in because it wasn't
ready at the time and now all your
processes get pushed back if not
cancelled for that night um and what if
instead of every day the data being
fresh enough you say no I need my data
closer to real-time right like maybe
you're working in the security realm and
if somebody does something there's a
breach of your system you don't want to
know about it tomorrow because you just
gave somebody 24 hours to take over your
network right you want to know about it
soon like as fast as possible and I work
in the security space so I'm always
dealing with a lot of data and here's
another thing and this is sort of on the
edge of what this problem is what if
we're you did all that work those SSIS
packages all the transformations the ETL
that's in your database but another
department needs that same data right
you're putting together accounting data
and what if you're doing a process is
slightly different than the other
department all of a sudden you guys
aren't in sync and you don't know why
you're writing customers higher and
they're writing them lower right like
there's there's there's some sort of
mismatch there and so that's one of the
problems that happens when you start
doing this as departments just sort of
silo themselves so this is where Apache
Kafka comes in and it is Kafka used to
call it Kefka um but I've been corrected
it when you do a podcast and in your
audience as developers we like to tell
each other that they're wrong so so I
get that a lot um so Apache Kafka is
it's a distributed event streaming
platform and
the crazy part about that is when you
say nobody understands what it means the
cool part is it can handle trillions of
events per day and don't take my word
for it
Microsoft does it with office 365
they're actually using a cluster of 10
kafka servers using HD insight and
they've got an article write-up about
how much they're doing throughput size
of data everything like it's amazing
stuff links in there oh and by the way
all these slides will be available I'll
go back at the end or whatever and I'll
give you the github page um so they do
this um it was originally created as a
messaging queue so if anybody's worked
with RabbitMQ or anything like that
you know data comes in gets popped off
the sack and then goes on right the big
difference between Kafka and something
like rabbit and queue is this is a
persistent highly scalable and fast data
queue so that's where it comes in it's
also known as a distributed commit log
so when a lot of people come from the
database world and they start working
with queues they have a hard time
wrapping their head around the fact that
this isn't data that you query right as
data comes in it just goes on top of
each other right every message that
comes in just keep stacking if you want
to go find data in that you basically
got to go through the entire commit log
of it and that's what this is right so
it was open source by Linkin LinkedIn in
2011 because they have a lot of data
they're kind of like the Twitter's and
the Facebook's of the world right like
they have a huge amount of data coming
in and what's cool is when they started
seeing this because they made it hyper
fast and distributed they're like oh
maybe this is more useful than just
another queueing system we can use this
for real-time streaming because it's so
fast at putting data and in getting data
out so what I want to tell you is that
if you can think of Kafka as like your
backbone for things to talk to each
other that whole problem where I said
that you know this database has
information over here they could benefit
this department right now the way that
people hook that up is they create
another SSIS package right and then they
set it up on a schedule to push things
over what if instead of that you have
data go through Kafka and everything can
just subscribe to the data
about and then that way when new data
comes in you have access to it
immediately and everybody has consistent
access to it right so what about a demo
I'm sure everybody wants to see what I'm
talking about but let's not get ahead of
ourselves
so here's the thing it helps it helps to
understand a little bit about the Kafka
or the case trains the Kafka streaming
world because there's a few different
parts to it and just as a heads up
there's a lot of streaming technologies
out there you've heard of probably
Apache spark storm there's a ton of
things right so why go with something
like this
the key is this I'm sure you all work in
places where you know let's say that I
think a lot of people here are not net
developers right so you have that net
you're probably using sequel server and
then some other front-end technology
right if you tell somebody hey I want to
add something to the stack there's a lot
of acid reflux that comes along with
that right like I don't want to
operationalize this who's gonna run it
who's gonna do this so that's a problem
and if you start going into things like
spark and all those there's a lot more
infrastructure you have to stand up it's
not just that right when you do Kafka
you get this with it and that was one of
the driving factors behind me going with
this stuff so with this it's talking
about a little bit so in Kafka you have
producers it's pretty easy those live
down here at the very bottom level all
they do is put data into a topic or the
queue right that's it you have consumers
they simply get data out of something
they subscribe to it so if you have a
topic out there anybody that cares and
has access to that topic can subscribe
to it so anytime a new message hits it
they're told about it that's how that
works so now you have streams applicants
and I want to point out here that your
productivity goes up as you come up here
because the codes easier right your
flexibility goes down as you're at the
top because obviously as you add more
abstractions to things the lower level
access to those other things that you
need disappear right it's the same type
thing when people do like xamarin forms
like you can do some amazing stuff with
it but if you need to start reaching
beyond what they've done there you no
longer you can use those
distractions you have to go straight to
iOS or Android right same type thing
here so in streams applications in this
middle here they have what's called a K
stream and more or less those are Java
applications and they are really
producers and consumers because the way
those applications work is they will
subscribe to a topic and say hey I care
about when data comes into this right
like maybe it's my accounting
information what data comes into it it's
gonna be a little application that runs
some sort of business logic and then it
pushes data back out to another topic
right so it's a it's a consumer and a
producer the difference is you also have
access to this thing called the DSL it's
their domain-specific language but it's
sort of simplistic you can do joins you
can do things that you can conceptually
think about that are sort of similar to
a database world right um down below
that they have what's called the process
or API so it's it's actually it's way
down here it is super complex because
you can control what happens as data
frames come in like you have full access
to everything it's way harder but then
up here at the top you have this thing
called K sequel and everybody coming
from a relational database background
kind of know sequel it's pretty easy
standard joins that kind of stuff right
so if you want to be super productive
you can do this but the amount of
functionality you get is fairly limited
but it is good for some use cases and
I'll show you that here in a minute so
all that said that's the background on
on what Kafka provides in terms of
streams and I'm going to show you what
I'm going to demo here today so I'm
gonna have a sequel server an
elasticsearch Kafka connect as a matter
of fact let's talk about that real quick
coffee connect as a service and really
all it is is consumer and a producer and
what it allows you to do is instead of
when you set up your SSI pack you just
say hey I want to go to server 2 and I
want to go to server 3 and all that kind
of stuff this is configuration based so
there's a lot of consumers out there or
what are they called connectors out
there that allow you to connect to JDBC
database is Google Cloud to AWS to Azure
or whatever right so there's all these
connectors that are configuration based
and I'll show you a couple of those here
in a minute
but it allows you to basically just say
hey I just want to pipe native from here
to here that's it I don't want to have
to set up a bunch of com
like stuff that's all I want to do all
right so let's talk through this here
what we're gonna do in this demo is I'm
gonna write a bunch of transactions to
the database right and as things go into
that database I basically want them to
then go to this kafka connector that I'm
going to say hey watch these tables and
when data hits those tables I want it to
then go into some specific topics that I
set up right so the whole the whole
point here is its configuration base I'm
not writing a bunch of code right and
then after that happens I want these two
things over here I'm going to have a
case equal server running which is
nothing more than a case stream
application that can support this the
sequel language on top of it I want
David to go to there and I want it to go
to here right so all these guys are
doing is subscribing to that topic in
Kafka right then like I said the
important part is you're probably not
just gonna listen to data and not do
anything with it
so after you do that I'm gonna have
these things feed data back into a new
topic in Kafka right once that happens
it's going to go back through another
connector that I've configured and once
that happens then it's going to go push
data back into sequel server and into
elasticsearch so the whole point is
instead of having a sequel server do
things like if you if you have a bunch
of order so what I'm doing is like a
user rewards type thing right so you
have a bunch of transactions that come
in that have values associated with them
in the olden days the way people would
do this in databases they'd write a
group by and so on and all that kind of
stuff and that's all fine when you have
a million records what happens when you
get to 20 million you know like like
anybody that's worked in sequel server
or any database for a long time
everything's great until it's not right
and it might just be that one extra
record you're like well how did it go
from you know two seconds to ten minutes
right so the whole point is offload that
work onto things that are distributed
they can do it on their own without
requiring something like sequel server
which notoriously is scale up add more
Hardware add more RAM add more drives
out all this these things over here
scale independently you add as many
nodes as you want and it just scales
that way so that's what we're gonna do
and so now we can start the demo all
right so hopefully this goes a little
bit better
what the the video did um alright so
there's quite a bit of just I'm not
gonna show you a ton of code I want to
show you the results of the code but
I'll point out some things as we go
right um let's see the time is all right
so first thing we're gonna do hey
anybody in here work with docker okay
quite a few um anybody work with docker
compose or no why
okay excellent so I'm not going to go
deep into it but everything that I'm
going to run is running in a docker
compose setup which means that I'm
basically you spin up about six or seven
different services or servers on my
machine with one command right which is
kind of nice
so right now you'll see here I'm
creating a sequel server instance Kabana
elasticsearch so that's the out stack
zookeeper which comes with Kafka because
this is what keeps everything in sync
the broker which is actually the thing
that stores the data is what it takes
the data in for Kafka schema registry
that's kind of interesting when you are
doing things in Kafka you can use this
game of registry which means that as
data comes in you can type it right so
it's kind of nice you could start there
it can create a whole world of problems
but you can also save a world of
problems you have Kafka connecting a
sequel server like I said that's another
service that runs and then control
center that so you can look at the Kafka
stuff it's something that comes from
confluent it's nice to be able to show
you what's in there okay sequel CLI and
then data Jim alright so these things
are running what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to connect to the sequel
server and I so I usually use this
that's a mess of my regular day stuff
but as your data studio if anybody
doesn't know here's a nice little tip
for you
it's cross-platform so if you're on Mac
if you're on Windows if you're on
whatever you can run this it uses like
the same type back in the visual studio
code does and it's really good for
presentations because I could increase
the font that kind of stuff right so um
it is a nice little tool so the first
thing we're going to do here is we are
going to create the database the only
thing that is a pain about this is it
doesn't save the connections for each
thing that you do so that things created
I've now created a database called
streaming DB alright the next thing I'm
going to do
and we'll talk through this here real
quick it's not all that interesting
other than just knowing what's there so
I'm creating these tables and really
I've got this user rewards table that's
really just your balances right that's
that's all it is so if you think about
if somebody's going to come up and
they're gonna shop but the rewards
points you don't have to sum up all the
transactions every time so that's that's
your ledger right or not your ledger
that's where you're storing the the
aggregates right then you're going to
have the transactions this is where the
data streams in and out and it is hot
now so this is coming off um so you're
going to put your transactions in there
and then this one this real-time one is
where I'm going to bring data back from
Kafka that I that I compute and
aggregate on the external things so that
I can spin up as many workers as I want
sort of I'll tell you why in a minute
alright so that's created now the next
thing I'm going to do is I'm gonna seed
some of this data just so I can have
some beginning balances nothing really
all that interesting here either but I
do want to show you a couple of things
here so you can see here the balance is
that's fine this is the interesting part
so what Kafka connect if you're using
the standard JDBC connectors they have
this thing that says hey you can watch a
particular column to find out when data
changes so I know when you go get data
out of sequel server and push it into
copy right well what kind of stinks
about that is if you are updating things
what are you gonna watch right you could
do a date stamp if you wanted but that's
kind of heavy-handed there's a thing in
sequel server called row version if you
had a column like that it automatically
every time a records touched it
increments it right and so what I'm
doing here is I'm just converting it to
a big int more or less just I think I
have a computer column on the table and
and so every time that connector sees
that number go up then it goes and
pushes that data over to connect write a
little bit of stuff that is painful and
so you realize what's going on alright
so now what I'm going to do and this is
way more convoluted than when it needs
to be um but really I'm just creating a
slow loop so that I can show you what's
happening right because it wouldn't help
you if I'm streaming a million events
and you all you see is just stuff
screaming across the screen so this is
basically just in
serving data into this transaction table
every half-second couple second whatever
like on a random thing so I'm going to
run this and then we'll get started on
the other part of it all right so this
thing's running we will see as a matter
of fact if I come here and I say
actually let me double click it okay
that other one's still open so if we
come up here and we connect and I run
this one so this is kind of like the
thing so that we can just see hey what's
actually going on behind the scenes and
so in fairness this is kind of what
people would do in the past right when
they're trying to get things out of
sequel server they're gonna go run a
bunch of aggregations right against the
live data and this is what I was talking
about like this is all fine and dandy
until you reach that point and then all
of a sudden these queries no longer come
back in time and then people start
thinking about oh well maybe we need to
batch these maybe we need to put them on
some sort of schedule whatever right so
this is what we're trying to avoid but
it's good for being able to see what's
here so a couple of things I want to
point out I've only got nine users right
I didn't want to go too big and then
over here you'll see that I'm
calculating the point balance that's
coming from the query above that's doing
the aggregations the streaming point
balance is coming out of that real time
table that I set up no data is in there
yet because I haven't actually hooked up
anything right and then same type thing
over here so I've got the points
redeemed I want to keep track of how
many people are spending so that's right
there and again this is coming from the
other table nothing in there yet so just
in a nutshell so we can see here and
then I've got the counts of transactions
now one thing that is frustrating want
to set up this demo is if you've ever
tried to set up a query that will do
random numbers and sequel server it
doesn't work well if you're doing it in
single query because you have to reseed
those values every time even with the
random thing that I get the
distributions not great everything like
at the end of this I'll have 27,000
records in one of these and I'll have
26,000 800 another one so it's not
perfect but it'll demonstrate the
purposes so now it's time to start
looking at Kafka now one thing I will
tell you about Kafka is it's not the
sexiest thing in the world there's not a
bunch of you eyes behind this thing
right so it's not like sequel server
where you go in and you start doing
things and everything feels glorious
right you type it according it comes up
it's not like that man if there's one
downfall to Kafka is there are not great
you eyes around it most everything is
CLI driven which great for scripting
great for automating not so great when
you're actually just trying to see
what's going on all right so the first
thing we want to do here is I'm going to
set up topics now something I want to
point out to you and maybe if I can make
this a little bit bigger oh that's a
little bit too big so you'll notice up
here I've got partitions set to five
this is really important so I said that
you can scale out applications with
Kafka that's only true based on number
of partitions so if you think about it
when you set up a worker a case streams
application that wants to work on data
it works on one slice so one partition
right so if you want to have multiple
workers stood up running then you have
to increase the number of partitions so
for the demo I've done five because
you'll see some interesting things that
happen here but that's important if I
hadn't set this up upfront set up the
topic with the partitions whatever
starts going to talk to Kafka is going
to create it with their defaults and
this is another frustrating thing is
everything has their own defaults case
equal does for some things do one some
things do five and the problem is when
you start trying to join data across
partitions or from different topics
everything has to have the same key on
the same partition so if you start
trying to join something if you have
three partitions and one in four
partitions in another and you try and
join user ID one from this one to user
ID on that one it might be on partition
one over here and partition two over
here and it's not going to work so you
have to use the same key hashing Technol
going across these things when you're
setting them up that's another key point
a lot of you are dotnet developers if
you start playing with this know that
out of the box the.net producer is not
the same hashing algorithm that the Java
ones are so you'll start you'll be
looking at your data go and why is this
missing and it's because it put it on a
different partition because it's hashing
the data differently so know that know
that when you're putting data up there
if you're using different languages that
have their own libraries pay attention
to that
all right so now what we're gonna do
we're going to go run this I'm just
calling the docker compose all I'm doing
is calling the shell script that is
inside the broker itself and I'm passing
this in and it's going to create the
topic it gives us it gives us a warning
all good developers ignore warnings so
don't worry about that the next thing
and anti-joke I think it might work we
have a project that has like 5,000
warnings and it's all sequel server
based stuff and everybody's just given
up hope all right so who created that
one and this last one all right so trust
that these are there we're gonna go look
at them in a second there's no data in
it they're just set up right so now what
we're going to do is I actually am going
to set up a case equal client so this is
about the best UI you're gonna get and
in Kafka which is sad so what you're
gonna see here this is the case equal UI
right it's amazing
so what this gives you the ability to do
is run queries at the command line and
we're gonna step through these and
here's a super important thing right
here
this Auto offset reset earliest I'm
going to show you what it means in a
minute but know that if you're trying to
run data if you're trying to run
applications again cop against Kafka I
think by default most everything says
they only want things from now right so
if you want to go back and get
everything that was historically put in
those topics you better set that
otherwise you're going to be saying why
am I missing all my data so this right
here is imperative in most cases when
people are trying to set up things so
let's drop this in here tells us it
worked
we'll trust that all right so now here's
the here's where we're going to start
getting in some pretty stuff so I'm
gonna drop this in and then we'll go
talk about it all right so if we look at
this thing right here all we're saying
is we want to create this table called
user rewards in encase equal okay
behind the scenes that's actually
getting stored in a topic
in Kafka okay here's the really
important thing to know in every single
person I've worked with on streaming
applications especially with case dreams
and Kafka they see table and they think
it's actually a table that's not what's
happening everything in Kafka still gets
stored and a queue the only difference
is it's it's it's a practice it's a
standard when you use a table you're
saying that every record in there is the
current state okay so instead of like
transactions rolling in with I paid ten
dollars five dollars or three pounds or
five pounds or whatever this is the
customer has spent fifteen pounds total
you have to think about it like that
it's up to you to make sure that that's
what you're doing all right but that's
the assumption so all I'm doing here is
I'm saying hey back it with this topic
that I just created a little while ago
apparently there's nothing in it right
so there won't be anything in that table
so the next one I'm going to do is a
stream and this is exactly what it
sounds like these are the actual
transactions so if we drop this thing in
you'll see here I'm pointing at the
transactions topic right that's what I'm
going to fill up with the individual
transactions that come across and a
stream is exactly what it sounds like as
data hits this thing will start picking
it up and doing things with it so it
makes things nice alright and then the
last thing I'm going to do here is I'm
going to set up this this user rewards
balance table right and I think I named
it pretty poorly I called it arti
balance like retweet I meant for
real-time so that's all that's gonna
happen here is this table is going to
have information in it oh here's another
key thing you'll notice I have the the
format is Avro it's not super important
for you to know about right now I just
have it in the back of your head if you
start playing with this so I don't
remember what talk it was earlier this
week people said you know JSON is great
for human readability it's terrible for
data compression because you're
repeating the properties the names
everything over and over and over right
ever move strips that out for you so
that's when I said that you have the
schema registry the schema for a record
gets stored up in that schema registry
right so in this case I've got user ID
points description that kind of stuff
right that way when the record comes
it's probably in some sort of a ray it's
in a binary but it's probably in an
array format right so instead of you
know user ID : one it's gonna store this
thing in a way more efficient format
that's gonna be faster and more
efficient right so just be aware Avro is
kind of like the de facto standard with
this stuff so that's that alright so now
here's the interesting thing let's get
into where we can actually look at some
data alright so keep in mind this is a
streaming application so what you're
going to expect to see here is data just
continually coming in right it's not
like a sequel query where you run a
query and you get your result set and
it's done that's not how this works but
nothing's coming out right well
nothing's coming out because we haven't
hooked up sequel server to Kafka yet
there's nothing that's piped in the data
across yet so that's where we're going
to do something else and you'll notice I
have a few tools open so postman all it
is is they've basically got a the
connector has a REST API endpoint that
you can call being set up connectors
destroyed connectors all that kind of
stuff so that's what I'm gonna do and
this is where I was telling you that
it's all configuration based now a
couple of key things to talk about here
is you'll notice that I've got sources
and sinks when you're talking about in
the Kafka world and probably a lot of
the big data world sources where you get
data from to put it into Kafka a sink is
getting data out of Kafka and drop it at
somewhere else right so that's just
that's their terminology so here's what
I'm going to do I am going to set up
this user rewards connector and this is
this is the configuration it looks like
a lot but it's really not it's a bunch
of boilerplate stuff but more or less
you're gonna have your connector to the
database you're gonna have the you're
gonna have the connection over to Kafka
so you're gonna have to tell it like
where the broker is and all that kind of
stuff I do have some interesting things
here called schema create key extract
key that's actually doing in line ETL
transforms on a per field basis so on
one of these I don't remember which one
it was exactly but on one of these I
actually have to convert a date/time
string into something that will be
recognized in Kafka as a date/time right
so you can do some of that stuff in line
here you'll see here I have this pole
interval so this one I think is set to
the max
which I don't even know how long that is
but all this means is I want this to
grab this data once more or less right
the way Kafka Connect works is you set
it up on a polling interval and so you
can tell it hey I only want new data
every 10 seconds every minute whatever
right it's up to you how frequently you
want it to get that data and push it
back over to Kafka so that's where you
control that so this is basically what
you do for both the sinks and the
sources it's really easy so I'm going to
set this one up if everything works then
I should have down here you'll see this
came out with the task right so I'm not
going to show you the other one doesn't
really matter it's the same thing we're
gonna hit Send and it echoes it back
anyway so you can see what happened and
I'm also going to set up these sinks
here right now
so we'll do this because these are the
things are going to push into the
database and this is the one that's
going to approach it weighted see if
they've finished and then this is the
one that's going to push into elastic
right now we should have data coming
across check this out so what happened
because I set this thing to auto offset
earliest it went back to the beginning
of everything and it went through it all
and so as new records come in we're
going to see these values change again
this is a live streaming application
this isn't a query that's running
against some fake set of data this as
these things come in as they're being
written to my table they're being
streamed across to Kafka and now I have
access to that data in Kafka now a
couple of key points here that are
actually really important when you start
messing with Kafka these first two
fields
that's your timestamp of when it came in
you have control over that you can tell
it with the timestamp is and this is the
key for the record if you start messing
with Kafka use a string as your key
don't mess with anything else you will
lose days you will lose sleep it's not
fun I've been there so that's important
than the things to the right are the
values that are coming out of that right
so that's cool we have data coming into
Kafka now now one thing I want to show
here is if we go to 9021 so this is the
control center for Kafka and when I say
UI is a challenge for these people
pretty sure high school kid did this
stuff Oh so here it's so awful I can't
even explain how bad this is all right
so here's the important part I can't
make it bigger because everything will
disappear because their UI is awful just
just take my word for it these are the
topics down here you'll see that there's
data coming through you have throughput
you'll see the replication factor on
these did I set those to five that's
interesting
oh so they actually miss calculus
interpret this these are the partitions
I have five partitions that's not
actually replication it's two different
things in Kafka you can replicate to the
number of servers you want and you have
partitions right so two different things
bad UI and they're lying about the
partitions here so any rate you see the
data is coming through we have these
things in here right it's nice to be
able to do a sanity check more or less
right that's that's the only reason I
ever come to this page all right so now
back to the next bits of this so we took
a peek at that now what we want to do is
we actually want to start aggregating
things so here is where I'm going to
have case equal do these aggregations as
they come in so let's paste that all
right so you can see here it's pretty
simple right it's basically what we did
and the sequel server query I'm gonna
say hey give me the max points redeem
and then I'm gonna sum the points and
I'm doing the negative one because I
want it to be a negative value as it
comes in right or I'm actually inverting
it because they were all negative so I'm
basically - I could have done the
absolute whatever Oh so that's coming in
as points for Dean right I'm doing the
aggregations in case equal so that this
stuff goes into a topic and then that's
probably already being replicated back
to sequel server now right so let's take
a look at what this thing looks up looks
like and what we're going to do is we're
just going to look at one user so this
is where I said the important part is
man that stinks so look at this I have
where user ID equal 8 or user 8 right
again this doesn't go to a specific row
right when you run this query as you go
home from the top of or the bottom of
that stack all the way to the
top so what we just saw stream out of
there and this is super important to
know because every single person that
sees coffee and they're like oh this is
amazing let's replace our server or our
database um I don't do that that's not
how this works right so this is going
through the entire stream and as new
data comes in here you're gonna see a
pop um because again this is a live
breathing data stream so the last thing
we're gonna do here is I'm going to get
those two fields together that I talked
about so the points were deemed and the
and the actual total number of points
that you've earned right or spent or
whatever so that's it these things are
all going into topics now so now it's
time to go back and look at what we've
got over here so I think I'm pretty good
on time so remember these are null
because there was no data in those
tables right and I think I actually kept
this thing alive
let's connect just so you can see again
I'll Wheaton right let's do that
so all I'm keeping in this table is the
balance right the the totals that are
going on so as data comes across that
are now being processed externally on
scalable infrastructure that's happening
and then coming back and being fed right
into sequel server right these are super
lightweight updates as opposed to
running these aggregations all the time
to find out what you want so like that
top one right now is 81 356 it's
different now 81 421 it's constantly
getting updated right and I could have
it on whatever polling interval I wanted
now if we go back over to it was this
one and we run this again here's the
cool part this stuff is happening now
granted I have this stuff trickling in
I'll show you a firehose blast in a
minute but look at this the point
balance is the same on these 104 32 the
streaming points are deemed is the same
20 256 now we might see some
discrepancies down here as it's trying
to synchronize data but I don't see any
right now but that's because it's
basically keeping up with everything's
happening I don't have a lot of data
through there right now but that's
really important so that's cool right I
didn't do a whole lot that you guys saw
to to make this happen
right I now have something that's
streaming this data all the time forget
that this was nights and nights and
nights of why and network and why isn't
this working right so this is this is a
template to start from if you ever want
to try this stuff because I have all
this up there on github like you can
truly go run it I've tried to put out a
readme and stuff so if you want to
follow this and play with it there's a
good way to get your feet wet so that's
all working and that's pretty awesome
because now you have stuff coming in
real time but the really cool part is I
have this go into multiple places now
which in the past like I said when you
have things like sequel server and
that's what you use them for everything
if you wanted to push it into another
place you're gonna go set up another
SSIS package and you're gonna set up all
the same type stuff hey I want to push
this there this there it's a lot of work
so what I'm going to do here is nothing
all that glamorous but we're gonna look
so you'll see here I have this index
down here this is when I set up that
that sync connector to push into
elasticsearch it's pushing it in that
index so I am by no means a wizard and
Kabana
or elasticsearch you don't have to be
that familiar with it just know that
this is really cool that this is
happening like this oh but what we're
gonna do did I come in hit save source
so you have to at least in here you're
supposed to tell a timestamp this is the
thing that I told you I had a transform
in to convert this to a real date so it
wasn't a string coming in and it's
basically so you can create these index
patterns so this is going to create it
now what we'll be able to do is we'll be
able to go look at this data and inspect
it right so if we come over here to
discover check this out
I now have a dashboard of all the
transactions that are coming in and all
I had to do was set up a configuration
to bring this in here good luck doing
that with much of anything else right so
this is really cool because now if I put
really important data in there instead
of just these transactions I can do some
interesting things right like maybe I
wanted to create dashboards maybe I
wanted search so I could come here and I
say hey I don't care about the points
let's look at what's going on here so I
wanna say visualize and these are all
the points that have been coming in but
this is a
really all that interesting because it's
not broken down in a way that makes any
sense so what we're going to do is we
are going to change the x-axis to be by
significant terms and we will make this
the user ID because that makes a lot
more sense we'll put that at twenty Oh
actually don't want that I want terms
because then I can order it so I'm gonna
make this one the user ID keyword I'm
gonna make it a sending so that we can
see all these things and we only have
nine of these okay that's fine and then
up here I actually want to change this
will keep the count there because that's
interesting let's add another metric
though so that's going to be the count
of transactions we got for the user
right that's what we're gonna be looking
at there and then here I'm gonna say you
know what I want to see the sum of
points that came in so I'm gonna sum
this and I'm going to choose the points
right and now one other thing we want to
do if I run this right now I hate
stacked charts I can't stand them
because it seems like data gets lost in
them so what I'm gonna do just for kicks
here is I'm going to set these things up
to where they run side by side so
instead of stacked will do this and now
if I mouse over these things you can see
hey user one has 106 points that came in
and I can search that stuff I can do a
lot of interesting things if I put a lot
of data in here to where I can go start
doing like if you're in Kabana you could
even do machine learning right like is
there anything that's anomalous here is
there anything that I should be aware of
whatever but the key is you dump that
data out over here and you can visualize
it right and that was all through a few
configurations so that's all cool every
time I show this stuff one caveat I have
to put out there for K sequel is when I
told you that your your functionality
goes down it really does you can do
simple things you can do joins you can
do aggregations but if you need to do
anything that's really parsing data or
anything like that or needing to reach
out and do other things
it falls on its face super fast and that
can be frustrating
the last thing I want to show you here
is it's actually kind of cool so first
off I need to open up something and this
is magic by the way I just figured out
how to do this the other day so if you
do this watch this look at that have
that whole thing come up that's this
amazing it's the little things in life
oh so don't worry about the fact that
it's really small right now because I'm
gonna point out there's certain things
that you should care about
but first what I want to do is I will
walk you through what this is so a case
tree map is Java I personally hate Java
and when I say hate like I can't there's
there's a certain level of hate that I
can't even go to I don't like typing out
string every time I'm going to do a
string right like I've fallen in love
with c-sharp and how how short the code
syntax is so if you're like me if you
hate something enough you'll find a
solution to it and the solution is
JetBrains created a language called
Kotlin it compiles down to the same
bytecode that java does it's amazing so
the syntax is very very similar
so the thing is basically when I went to
do this I took my java code that was
working and i right-clicked it and I
said convert to Kotlin and that was it
right so if you ever find yourself in
the java world and hating java know that
Kotlin could be your friend um so let's
take a look here it's actually not that
complex what you're gonna see here is
like with a lot of code most of its
boilerplate so the main the main method
here this is the application that's
going to run and here's the important
part to know to this case stream
application could run anywhere as long
as it can connect to your Kafka broker
to run on a laptop
it can run on a server it can run in
kubernetes which is how I do it
oops um sorry about that um you could
actually have this thing run anywhere as
long as it can connect so truly this is
distributed and you can do your compute
just about any way you want to
so with this back to this the transform
streams that's nothing important this
load environment variables all that is
are the properties that I've set up for
it it's the connections you have the app
name up there which is counting
really this is again boilerplate nothing
all that glamorous um the stream
properties this is where I'm just
setting those development environment
properties to those parameters for Kafka
this is where the work happens and this
build topology because everything in
Kafka is called a topology when you're
doing this in a case dream world because
it says okay I've got something that's
listening to this topic after that it
transforms over here so it kind of draws
out this graph right that's really
what's happening so up here what we say
is I have this input topic I got that
from the development thing that's the
the transactions coming in it might
actually even tell me I don't know
down here so you have things coming in
now here's one thing that really kind of
stinks about it is I think Steve you
were talking about the JSON serializer
stuff right so one of the things that's
really really irritating is if you're
going to work with data in in Kafka
you've got it you've got to marshal that
data in and out of objects right
otherwise it doesn't know what the types
are so everything you do in Kafka has
what's called a Saturday and I don't see
it this is basically what it is though
so basically when you define it you have
to tell it what type the key is again
always always make it a string if you
care about your sanity and then you're
going to have another type here which
this is something that I've defined and
another Java class it's a simple
boilerplate type thing right so
basically data is going to come in here
and then I'm going to say group it by
the key I want to do it by the user ID
which is already the key on the data
home to group it by the key and get the
count and then I do another thing down
here I have to turn it back into a
stream so up here you'll see I have a K
table so again when you do the group by
key it's giving the latest value of what
it is for that particular user but then
if I want to be able to do and push it
back out to a topic I have to turn it
back into a stream of just redundant
code that you do in these but you have
the full power of Java if you need to
reach out like where stream starts see
meme really interesting to me is if you
have machine learning models or
something like that and you want to
apply that last calculated model to
every record that comes in this is where
you do it right if if you have certain
business logic that needs to group and
get things this is where you can do that
kind of stuff and again like one of the
use cases we have is we have IP
validation right and if you've ever
looked at IP validation it's not fun
there's Java libraries for that so you
can just include that library use it and
then you just go on about your way so
all that's happening here is this stuff
happens and at the very end you'll see
there's two things that are interesting
to us right now is you'll see this print
function this print function is what
we're going to see come out on the
console here that's going to slow things
down but it allow you to see it and then
the next thing is I'm gonna take this
data push it into a new topic and I'm
going to take that data and I'm gonna
push it into another topic now we're not
actually going to go look at those
topics because that's not what I want
you to see what I want you to see is how
this works when they're parallelized so
now it's time to get into the fun stuff
this is this is the part that everybody
asked about every time I did this demo
it was like okay I guess I need to
figure out how to show this all right so
the first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna follow the logs of the Kafka
broker so what I'm doing here is I'm
looking for the word rebalance all right
because what's gonna happen is every
time I online another instance of this
stream app that is going to work on this
data in parallel the broker is going to
start rebalancing itself to say okay I
need to put more work over to this one
more work over to this one than this one
right so we want to see that happen so
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to start up this jar so I've
already compiled this thing so check it
out this thing starting up and cool this
thing came up here and said hey I see
something new came up and it's starting
to push data over to that right now one
thing I want to show you here is this is
really really really key here and if I
can zoom really
okay I guess I'm not gonna zoom there um
so that's technology right oh so here's
the key part I told you we have five
partitions this one says the current
active tasks are partition zero one two
three and four this thing's got all of
them right this one worker is
responsible for handling all the data
across all partitions this is where
people go holy crap this is amazing
because now hey this thing's getting
bogged down I need to spend out more
workers right and any more like
kubernetes you set up the things that
hey if the CPU utilization goes bonkers
or whatever just fire another pot up
right that's what you're going to do and
that's what we do in the real world so
if I do the same thing here say jar I
run it now watch up here top left sees
that we have another one it's
rebalancing now check this out let's go
back to this so that one's frozen there
and you can see this one this one's
rebounce now it has zero one two three
and four no wait I stopped it there this
one now has zero one and four
this one has two and three so it
redistributed the work for everything so
now as you need more processing power
you have the ability to do it just by
starting another thing because it knows
its application ID that it registered
with the broker the broker says okay I
have another worker I'm gonna put you
online
now what's interesting and not obvious
to a lot of people when they first start
getting into this is we're gonna spin up
a bunch of other ones alright and what
you'll see is some of this data will
start disappearing from some of these
other ones right so now this one's
responsible for two and three and this
got user seven and one this one has user
two six and three this one doesn't seem
to be doing anything it kind of doesn't
make sense right it's got partition one
so here's the thing that's interested
about this remember I told you it hashes
data as it goes into Kafka if it hatches
the key and that key doesn't land on
partition one
no data ever lands there right so this
is an important thing that people need
to understand when they start working
with a lot of big data is some people
say oh well let's just partition
everything and put all the customers on
one what if you have one customer that
gets 20 million records an hour another
one that gets a thousand an hour right
it doesn't make sense so you have to
find a partitioning scheme that makes
sense for you but the key here is
nothing's going to this one because when
it hashed that user underscore one user
underscore two when it dropped it on a
partition partition one's not one more
any data is going to go but here's the
cool part so let's go ahead and fire the
rest of these up so it's going to redo
that up there all these are going to
redo themselves as well do the same
thing here right so at the end of all
this you might have one of these things
just sitting idle because it's like hey
I don't need it right don't need it at
all not gonna do anything some of these
are getting data in and you can see the
ones that are doing it and then the
other ones are basically just sitting
around doing nothing right but the cool
part is let's look at this one up here
that's actually getting some data and
let's kill this one right now the broker
is going to see that something came
offline it's gonna re distribute
everything and now that data gets picked
back up and works and the way Kafka
works and these streaming apps work is
they work off what's called offsets so
you don't actually lose anything so if
this thing dies in the middle of
whatever it's doing it was managing an
offset I had record number 100 right and
it writes that back to another Kafka
topic so all that data is stored in the
broker so if that thing dies when
something else goes to pick it back up
it says hey let's start at record 101
right so all this stuff happens for you
automatically just by using the
framework so that is a vast majority of
what I have there and I think yeah I
left right out of about ten minutes for
questions so no I didn't all have three
minutes for questions all right so
that's it for that so if anybody has any
questions obviously and man whatever I'm
not messing with that all right so
there's that so anybody have any
questions about this it's a whole lot
yeah
no you're not going to change without
losing anything you're probably going to
end up recreating and then and then pipe
in that data over to something else I
mean that being honest like one of the
things about Kafka is it's a it's very
efficient at what it does but there's
not a lot of tooling around that kind of
stuff right like you can delete topics
and you do something you can repartition
topics but if you want to change the
repartition scheme then that means your
applications have to be aware that hey
what the applet what the the
partitioning scheme used to be just
changed and so now it's going to be on
you in the application side to manage
that it's probably not worth it it's
probably better to move that data you
know take it offline for a minute move
the data get it in the partition scheme
you want and that way your application
logic doesn't get complex right so that
that would be my suggestion for people
who couldn't here he was basically
saying hey if you if you realize that
you partitioned and you hash your keys
wrong how easy is it to move over to a
new way of doing it it won't be so
you'll probably want to reset up those
topics with the partitions and the
hashing that you want anybody else know
yeah
no so the question is when I mentioned
that Nets hashing algorithm they used by
default is different than the one that
Java uses by default are they are they
just different implementations no it's
actually the same stuff so I forget what
the exact name of the one is it's
something random is what Java uses and
the one that dotnet uses is something
else by default but they have the same
base set of algorithms you can make your
own you can make your own hashing
algorithm that you want so you can put
your data on the partitions you want
no they just selected a different one by
default so almost all the libraries that
are out there for consumers and
producers are the same C++ library that
was written that are wrapped for the
different languages so if you're doing
Ruby dotnet any of those it's the same
underlying code they just have their
different wrappers and whoever the
default for that didn't do the same one
that Java did so that's a yeah
so no no the way that works is um and
you know when I showed you the the row
version or whatever so the query I put
in basically said hey look for this
particular column and so what happens is
I have a query that says how you select
everything from the table where you know
this field is you know newer and so
behind the scenes the coffee connector
is always storing the latest state for
what it got for that field so if the
last record number it got was a hundred
then it's only gonna say hey we're
greater than 100 it's doing it for you
yep yep yep so you index that field
absolutely and there's another thing too
is there are commercial connectors
available I'm using just the JDBC one
for this but there's one that has
changed data capture specifically for
sequel server so you can even hook it up
nicer and just say hey every time
something happens fire it off right
inside there you go okay so you would
probably do something very similar to
what I did here hey and if anybody was I
forget you probably can't hear so what
he asked was is this thing pulling the
whole table every time or is it just
grabbing the latest records its grabbing
the latest records because of the
configuration I put in anybody else
we're good alright awesome well thank
you very much and enjoy the rest of the
day
[Applause]